[Música]
vamos a hacer la actualización de las
noticias económicas en directo América
con Juan Pablo lucumi bienvenido
nuevamente Juan Pablo Gracias vamos a
actualizar la llegada de celular
Argentina desempolva el proyecto de una
única moneda suramericana tiene
factibilidad cuéntenos pues este es un
plan Esta es una estrategia se ha
hablado de esto en el pasado se está
como dice ustedes empolvando y vamos a
ver pues hasta donde avanza pero este
fue el comunicado que ambas partes
publicaron ayer desde Buenos Aires según
la casa rosada y dice tenemos la
intención de superar las barreras a
nuestros intercambios simplificar la y
modernizar las reglas y fomentar el uso
de las monedas locales también decidimos
avanzar en las discusiones sobre una
moneda suramericana común que pueda
usarse tanto para los flujos financieros
como comerciales reduciendo Los costos
operativos y reduciendo nuestra
vulnerabilidad externa cierro comillas
Esa es la intención Y definitivamente
podría ser una gran noticia Ángela para
la región Pero antes
hay que evaluar si verdaderamente es
viable se debe estudiar los parámetros
de una moneda común como las cuestiones
Fiscales de papel en las cuestiones
Fiscales de ambos países pero también el
papel de los bancos centrales y hasta el
tamaño de la economía en ocasiones
anteriores El Banco Central de Brasil
frenó la iniciativa y ahora se espera
que el proyecto pase a través de un
programa del banco interamericano de
desarrollo uno de los requisitos mínimos
que algunos analistas han dicho que se
necesita para la moneda común es que
exista un nivel de confianza alto por al
menos pues estas dos economías unas
políticas macroeconómicas suficientes y
también establecer que ambos países
tengan un Rango de inflación similar y
pues como podemos ver Argentina no
superó al 100% como se esperaba para
diciembre pero está en un 94 se espera
también la previsión del 98 y por el
contrario Brasil está Pues en una brecha
muy diferente entonces si se nivela pues
es una de las una de las parámetros que
se quiere para poder hacer esta moneda
pero ya veremos qué sucede bueno se ve
complicada la cosa sí bastante vamos a
cambiar radicalmente de tema en Japón el
Primer Ministro dio importantes anuncios
de financiación qué detalles entregó
Ángela fue chida Pues dijo que el país
se enfrenta a un entorno de seguridad
delicado que no se veía en la región
desde final de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
y que debían prepararse para esos mismos
niveles por esta razón pretende casi que
duplicar su presupuesto de defensa hasta
los 332 mil millones de dólares así como
mejor mejorar sus capacidades en el
ciberespacio e inteligencia Y aunque
para alcanzar este monto el país usa
gran parte de medidas de reformas
Fiscales una buena porción Debe llegar
por medio de un posible aumento de
impuestos algo que podría traer aún más
críticas para el Primer Ministro japonés
el otro tema del que habló fue la tasa
de natalidad qué pasa con la población
de Japón Ángela Pues el país de más de
125 millones de personas ha estado
disminuyendo su población Durante los
últimos 14 años y el gobierno Espera que
para 2060 lleguen a los y seis coma
siete millones de personas recordemos
Ángela que una población que se reduce y
envejece tiene enormes implicaciones
para la economía pues se reduce su mano
de obra también y Por ende su fuerza
nacional Esto fue lo que dijo el Primer
Ministro
se espera que el número de bebés nacidos
el año pasado caiga por debajo de los
800.000 no podemos perder el tiempo en
las políticas para los niños y el apoyo
a la crianza de los hijos debemos
establecer una sociedad económica que
priorice a los niños y cambiar la tasa
de natalidad en este repaso económico
del mundo Vamos hasta Irak hay un nuevo
dirigente del Banco Central de ese país
hay cambios empiezan a ver cambios en
ese país también y todo por la caída de
la moneda ya lo veremos este lunes el
Primer Ministro de ese país decidió
reemplazar al gobernador del Banco
Central hablamos de mustafa galette
quien ocupaba el cargo desde 2020 la
decisión llegó luego de una semana de
caída de la moneda local estamos
hablando del dinar iraquí el dinar tocó
nuevos mínimos el viernes alcanzando
alrededor de
1.670 por dólar lo que supone que la
moneda ha perdido casi el 7% de su valor
desde mediados de noviembre de 2022 los
mercados de iraks se han visto afectados
por la caída de la moneda y salpica
otros sectores como el de petróleo donde
muchos ya están viendo como su poder
adquisitivo disminuye ahora
serálak el encargado del Banco Central
un cargo que parece que será solo por un
tiempo porque se le denominó como
gobernador interino Cómo abre la jornada
en términos de indicadores pues vamos
con noticias tecnológicas y también lo
veremos más adelante con el tema de
Netflix y Spotify en Asia las acciones
reportaron ganancias Aunque la mayoría
de los mercados permanecieron cerrados
por el día feriado del año nuevo lunar
las bolsas en Europa siguen en su
mayoría reportando ganancias luego de
que los mercados monetarios descartaran
en un 98% la posibilidad de que el Banco
Central de Estados Unidos aumente las
tasas en un 25 25 puntos básicos el
próximo mes pero algo que también
influyó considerablemente fue el máximo
del euro en los últimos nueve meses y su
cifra del día renovada la cifra no es
tan positiva pero un 6% de la plantilla
laboral de Spotify será recortada el
anuncio se sumó a los despidos de estos
primeros días del año de grandes
tecnológicas como Microsoft y alphabet
de Google sin mencionar los masivos
despidos de otras tecnológicas que
recordará usted como Amazon Netflix esto
el año pasado Pero por supuesto que lo
recuerdo y una pésima noticia para la
economía y para los trabajadores seguro
estaremos analizando ese tema acá
gracias a usted Juan Pablo Antonio